empecemos por hablar qué tan
determinantes son estas elecciones
locales para fortalecer el poder de
morena y del presidente lópez obrador
buenas buenas tardes muchas gracias
antes que nada mala
auditorio pues si estas elecciones son
muy importantes espera efectivamente
como dices que la fuerza política del
presidente en los gobiernos locales
aumente no tienes la mitad tiene 18
gubernaturas un poquito más de la mitad
y al menos espera que va a ganar 4 que
le darían digamos dos terceras partes
hay una gubernatura que es la más grande
que está muy reñida y aguascalientes
bueno la conserva el opositor para
el partido del presidente ha crecido
desde la posición de amlo en 2018 pues
paso de gobernar en sólo seis estados a
tener la posibilidad de controlar más de
la mitad como usted lo dice que implica
esto para la política mexicana y sobre
todo para otros partidos tradicionales
como el pan o el pri
muy bien en méxico a partir del 2018 se
observa un sentimiento de la ciudadanía
por
partidos distintos los partidos
tradicionales como bien dice pri-pan
incluso el perro de don de subte morena
digamos que no tienen muy contentos a la
población pues por varios sucesos de
corrupción y además el crecimiento de la
inseguridad en el país es así como
morena que es un partido que se crea en
2015 logra darle la presidencia a este
candidato de izquierda andrés manuel
lópez obrador quien digamos fue uno de
los principales contendientes en las
elecciones previas de 2012 y de 2006
va creciendo su apoyo actualmente
mantiene 66
bueno en esta selección
es que aprenden el apoyo al monólogo y
en medio de este reacomodamiento de los
partidos cómo influye en estas
elecciones locales en los comicios
presidenciales que se esperan para el
digamos que al menos he estado
observando la tendencia a nivel nacional
hacia qué partidos vamos digamos morena
en gana en 2018 con la presencia de
andrés manuel lópez obrador logran la
mayoría casi absoluta de la cámara
dictados de un poquito menos en el
senado en alianza con otros dos partidos
más pequeños
y los partidos tradicionales han perdido
fuerza y presión aunque en la segunda
legislatura que se instan a en 2021 en
las elecciones del 2021 morena precio un
poquito en
la fuerza parlamentaria
pero en la oposición están ha crecido
muy poco apenas tiene poder de veto en
el pómulo conjunto estas elecciones son
muy importantes y tal vez también para
los partidos tradicionales porque están
en juego
si podrán sobrevivir